so today we're going to be looking at
this package called a squeeze which
allows us to build GG plots without
having to type any code at all so a
super useful for exploratory data
analysis or if you just want to generate
these GG plots without having to type
also pretty useful for that so in order
to get started all you have to do are
run these two lines install that
packages squeeze and then library of
squeeze this will install the package
and then load it up into your art studio
and then if you go up to the top in art
studio you'll see this button that says
add ins you click on that and you should
see something that says ggplot2 builder
but before we open that up I'm gonna go
ahead and open up our data frame that
would be working with called serial
which has the names of some serials the
manufacturers some nutritional info and
the ratings so let's go ahead and open
up our ggplot2 builder and you see we
get this screen that says select a
dataset so I'll click serial we have the
option to keep our variables or discard
some of them but I'm gonna go ahead and
keep them all and you'll see that
there's a legend showing us the types of
variables that our columns are so most
of these are continuous but we've got
some discrete ones and an ID up here you
also have the option to camaris your
variables in case you want to do that
but I'm gonna go ahead and leave
everything the way it is
so I'll click validate imported data
great so we have this box with all of
our variables or columns and then we
have some boxes underneath and if we
drag our variables into these boxes
it'll start generating our plots there's
also this button here that shows us the
types of plots that we can work with
these are all that I think the default
GG plots we've also got the option to
add labels or titles to choose different
colors or color palettes aims of our GG
plot and the position of the legend to
filter out some of our data and then
lastly to export our GG plot whenever we
generated into our art studio or just
download it as a image or a PowerPoint
file so I want to see if there's a
relationship between the rating of these
cereals and the calories of the cereals
because my hypothesis is that the higher
calories the cereal the better it will
taste and the higher the rating will be
but let's see if that holds any water so
grab calories and put it down in the X
and you can see that plot is already
generated the marina crab trading throw
it down into ry and we get this scatter
plot now it's a little small so I'm
gonna go ahead and increase the size and
I also want to see if there's a
relationship I kind of see it's trending
downwards but just to confirm let's go
ahead and add a smooth line and we can
see that it is interestingly enough a
general downward trend and then it kind
of flattens off after 120 calories so
that's pretty cool but I'm gonna go
ahead close out of this reopen our
ggplot2 builder let's make another graph
so again we'll keep the same settings
and if you never use tableau or even the
Excel pivot charts you'll see that the
interface is really similar so not too
difficult to learn
now the other plot I want to build is
showing the ratings between two
manufacturers so civically Kellogg's and
General Mills to see who has the better
cereals so we'll grab our manufacturer
names put that in our X grab our sorry
grab a rating which is down here throw
it into our Y and we get a box plot
that's automatically generated but let's
say we wanted a violin chart or
something we go ahead up here and hit
violin and you can see that it just
automatically changes our plot for us
there also some other options like the
bar but you can see that there are also
some other options that are disabled
because they only work if you have the
right data type inside of these boxes so
we'll leave our box plot we're gonna
also grab manufacturer name and throw it
in Phil just to get a legend on the
right side and I mentioned that we only
want to look at General Mills and
Kellogg's so we're gonna filter out some
of this data down here and just X out
all the stuff we don't want just like
that and then the last thing is just
adding some titles and labels awesome
just like that and once we're done we
can go ahead and click export in code
and hit this that says insert code into
scripts and all it does is it puts it
right in our studio which is perfect so
once we close out of this you can see
that we if we run all this code I'm
actually not going to run it
is if there's in this line that filters
out our data permanently which I don't
want to do so I'm actually going to call
this serial two and call this serial to
just so we're not overwriting our
original serial variable I'll run this
and it creates our new serial two data
frame with just general mills and
Kellogg's I'll load in our T G plot to
library and then I'll run our GG plot
and you can see just like that it
generates this plot for us so a squeeze
is actually really useful if I didn't
know GG plot that well it definitely
would have taken me some time and a lot
of googling to figure out exactly how to
get this into this amount of code but I
will say that it does have its
shortcomings I'd say a squeeze is kind
of glitchy sometimes and it sometimes
will try to do something and a ton of
warnings will pop up so for instance if
I grab cereal and I want to do the
rating and calories and we also have the
legend or sorry we're coloring by these
points and then we grab a smooth line we
try doing that we just get a ton of
warnings so this software isn't perfect
we can X out of all these and it will
actually whoops it will actually give us
what we want but it is still a little
glitchy I will say though that it is
great that it can import whatever the
plot is it can convert that into code
and give that to us it would be nice to
actually be able to build my own ggplot
and then somehow get import that code
into the squeeze interface so I could
further modify it that being said I
think that this program is great though
but if you're trying to learn ggplot2
I'd say that this squeeze kind of access
training wheels which isn't a bad thing
I think that can be really useful anyway
that's pretty much it for this video
thanks for watching and I hope you
learned something and I'll catch you in
the next one